do you think of as an interesting idea
this thought experiment that will live
in a simulation
and in general do you think we'll live
in a simulation
so the Nick bostrom's idea about the the
simulation
is typically
couched in a physicalist framework yes
so there's the bottom level
there's some programmer and a physical
space-time and they have a computer that
they've programmed brilliant cleverly
where they've created conscious entities
so you have the hard problem of
Consciousness right the standard hard
problem How could a computer simulation
create a Content which isn't explained
by that simulation Theory but then the
idea is that the next level the the
entities that are from the that are
created in the first level simulation
then can write their own simulations and
you get this this nesting
so so the idea that um this is a
simulation is fine
but the idea that this starts with a
physical space I think isn't for there's
different properties here the the
partial rendering and to me that's the
interesting idea is not whether the
entirety of the universe is simulated
but how efficiently can you
um
create interfaces that are convincing to
all
other entities that can appreciate such
interfaces how little does it take
because you said like partial rendering
or like temporal ephemeral rendering of
stuff only render the tree falling in
the forest when there's somebody there
to see it it's interesting to think how
can you do that super efficiently
without having to render everything and
that to me is one perspective on the
simulation just like it is with video
games right where video game doesn't
have to render every single thing it's
just the thing that the Observer is
looking at
right there is actually that's a very
nice question and there's a whole groups
of researchers that are actually
studying in virtual reality what what is
the sort of the minimal
requirements on this system what how
does it have to operate to give you an
immersion experience to give you the
feeling that you have a body to to get
you to take it real and and there's
actually a lot of really good work on
that right now and it turns out it
doesn't take that much you do need to
get the perception action Loop tight and
you have to give them the perceptions
that they're expecting if they want them
to but if you you can lead them along if
you give them perceptions that are close
to what they're expecting you can then
maybe move their reality around a bit
yeah it's a tricky engineering problem
especially when you're trying to create
a product
that cost little but that's I it feels
like an engineering problem not a deeper
scientific problem
um or meaning obviously it's a
scientific problem but as a scientific
problem it's not that difficult to trick
us uh descendants of Apes but here's
here's a case for just us you know our
own if this is a virtual reality that
we're expressing right now so here's
something you can try for yourself
if you just close your eyes
and look at
your experience in front of you to be
aware of your experience in front of you
what you experience is just like a
modeled dark gray but there's all sort
of there's some Dynamics to it but it's
just dark gray but now I ask you
instead of having your attention forward
put your attention backward what is it
like behind you with your eyes closed
hmm
and there it's like nothing
it's real
so what is going on here what what am I
experiencing back there
this is right was it's I don't know if
it's nothing it's it's like I guess it's
the absence of it's not even like
Darkness or something it's it if it's
not even Darkness there's no there's no
qualia to it
and yet there is a sense of being and
that's the interesting thing there's a
sense of being back so I close my if I
put my attention forward I just I have
the quality of a gray model thing but
when I put my attention backward there's
no quality at all but there is a sense
of being yeah
I I personally uh now you haven't been
to that side of the room I have been to
that side of the room so for me memories
I start I'm I start playing the engine
of memory replay
which is like I I take myself back in
time and think about that place where I
was hanging out in that part that's what
I see when I'm behind so that's an
interesting Quirk of humans too we're
able to we're collecting these
experiences and we can replay them in
interesting ways whenever we feel like
it and it's almost like being there but
not really but almost
that that's right and yet we can go our
entire lives on this you're talking
about the minimal thing for VR we can go
our entire lives and not realize that
all of my life
it's been like nothing behind me yeah
yeah we we we're not even aware that all
of our lives
if you just just for the just pay
attention close your eyes pay attention
to what's behind me we're like oh holy
smoke it's totally scary I mean it's
like nothing there's no quality there at
all how did I not notice that my entire
life we're so immersed in the simulation
we buy it so much yeah I mean uh you
could see this with with children right
you know with persistence you know you
could do the peek-a-boo game you can
hide from them and appear and they're
fully tricked and in the same way we're
fully tricked
there's nothing behind us and we assume
there is
and that's really interesting